[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
mirarlo en la wikipedia como se llama el
presidente de chiná
efectivamente el país más poblado del
mundo la segunda economía más grande del
planeta y casi nadie puede decirme el
nombre de su presidente
[Música]
y la república popular de china es un
país oficialmente comunista de hecho su
presidente que se llama xi jinping es
también el presidente del partido
comunista que es prácticamente el único
partido político con representación
oficial en este país
algo pese a ser comunista china es
también el hogar de muchas de las
mayores fortunas del mundo sus empresas
son cada vez más competitivas en el
mercado internacional y no sólo eso
china es también el principal destino de
las inversiones de las empresas
occidentales
en otras palabras china es al comunismo
lo mismo que ahora un play es al humor
inteligente pero esperad un momento
podríamos decir entonces que china es un
país capitalista existe de verdad libre
mercado en este lugar hoy vamos a
contestar a esta pregunta pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de perspectiva
histórica
[Música]
el gran salto adelante en 1927 china era
una república supuestamente gobernada
por un partido liberal que se llamaba el
comitán
y digo supuestamente porque tenían en
aquel momento dos guerras árabe por un
lado estaban los japoneses invadiendo
buena parte del país y por el otro el
partido comunista chino liderado por
este señor que vemos aquí que se llamaba
mao tse tung intentaba hacerse con el
poder después de la segunda guerra
mundial los nipones se van para su casa
con el rabo entre las piernas y los
comunistas terminan haciéndose con el
gobierno
así que en 1949 mao tse tung se
convierte en el primer presidente de la
república popular china y exilio a todos
los partidarios de comitán a una isla
muy pequeñita que es lo que hoy
conocemos como taiwán en sus primeros
diez años de mandato
mao intentó industrializar el país con
el dinero que le llegaba de la unión
soviética pero esto no era una tarea
fácil dado que china tiene más de 1400
millones de habitantes además tras la
muerte de stalin las relaciones entre
china y la unión soviética se enfriaron
bastante ya que para máó los sucesores
de stalin eran unos tibios burgueses así
que a finales de los años 50 nos
encontramos con que no hay dinero y por
eso no decidió sacar la madre de todas
las campañas políticas a la que llamó el
gran salto adelante en cuatro años
colectivizó todas las propiedades que
había en china incluyendo viviendas y
hasta los aperos de labranza de los
campesinos
las granjas pasaron a ser como unas
autogestionadas con unos objetivos de
producción marcados por el estado
concretamente el objetivo de máó
consistía en quintuplicar la producción
agrícola de china en sólo unos poquitos
años y por supuesto quien se opusiera a
todas estas medidas o no consiguiera
llegar a los objetivos de producción
corría el riesgo de que le metieran en
la cárcel o incluso le condenaron a
muerte tachándole de
contrarrevolucionario así que los
campesinos chinos se vieron obligados a
duplicar o incluso triplicar sus
jornadas laborales y los oficiales que
se dedicaban a controlarles y asegurarse
de que cumplían con los objetivos de
producción mentían a sus superiores para
que no les pudieran tachar de burgueses
[Música]
pero no sólo eso para poder
industrializar el país
mao necesitaba acero y como ya no se lo
vendían de la unión soviética y tampoco
tenía dinero para comprarlo en ningún
otro lugar ordenó que todas las granjas
tuvieran su propio horno casero de
fundición de esta forma los agricultores
no sólo tenían que labrar la tierra sino
que también tenían que buscar distintos
objetos de metal para poder fundir los y
como en este caso también había unos
objetivos de producción impuestos desde
pekín en muchos casos tenían que llegar
a fundir sus propios aperos de labranza
para poder cumplir con las metas igual
fue el resultado se estima que murieron
entre 18 y 45 millones de personas
algunos por hambre y agotamiento y otros
directamente asesinados por el régimen
fijaros en las cifras e incluso tomando
los números más bajos estamos hablando
del equivalente de la población de chile
tras este fracaso tan estrepitoso a mao
les salieron muchos enemigos dentro de
su propio partido gente que defendía una
ciudad
apertura al mercado internacional y una
interpretación un poquito más moderada
del comunismo el principal líder de este
movimiento fue este señor que veis aquí
que se llamaba den xiaoping autor de la
famosa frase
igual que el gato sea blanco o negro
mientras café ratones tras la muerte de
mao deng xiaoping y sus partidarios
consiguen hacerse con el control del
partido comunista chino estamos ya en el
año 1979 y esto será el principio de lo
que podríamos llamar
y la que conocemos hoy en día el nuevo
gobierno chino se encuentra con un país
en la más absoluta miseria y donde
además es muy difícil hacer cualquier
reforma política porque por un lado
china tiene una población enorme y por
el otro medio partido comunista está en
contra de cualquier cambio así es que
qué hizo den xiaoping pues cambiará el
sistema político a trocitos y así es
como surgió la idea de las zonas
económicas especiales que son provincias
en las que se aplican unas leyes
distintas a las que operan en el resto
del país
china mantiene su sistema comunista en
todo el territorio y menos en la
provincia de shenzhen donde se permite
que se instalen empresas privadas
extranjeras y además se ofrecen
condiciones fiscales muy favorables así
es como llegan las primeras empresas
privadas atraídas por los salarios bajos
y en poco tiempo la ciudad de shenzhen
pasa de ser esto
el éxito de estas zonas especiales fue
arrollador y en pocos años se crearon
muchas más y no sólo eso además
sirvieron como modelo para que se vieran
los beneficios de abrir la economía
china gracias a estas islas de libre
mercado fue mucho más sencillo convencer
a los gerifaltes del partido comunista
chino de las ventajas de modernizar el
sistema y por eso en el año 2007 ocurre
una cosa que podría sonar totalmente
contradictoria en un país que se dice
comunista
china aprueba la ley que protege la
propiedad privada
[Música]
por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música de rock house un
grupo de rock duro de san sebastián en
españa que nos ha mandado su música si
os gusta podéis encontrar más en los
links de la descripción
y yo os preguntaréis significa esto que
los líderes del gobierno chino
quieren convertir su país en una
democracia occidental lo cierto es que
no de hecho en los años 80 fruto de
todas estas reformas económicas muchos
estudiantes se reunieron en la plaza de
tiananmen en pekín para exigir al
gobierno que de igual forma que había
abierto a la economía también podía
abrirse en otros aspectos como derechos
civiles derechos políticos etc
y la respuesta fue una brutal represión
por parte de den xiaoping y es que
queridos amigos
este hombre quería reformar el país pero
son un poquito y ahora es cuando muchos
pensaréis que el sistema político chino
sería un sistema que combina el libre
mercado con una dictadura verdad pues no
y ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
el sistema económico tienen en china una
de las claves del capitalismo de libre
mercado es que casi todo el peso de la
economía cae sobre los hombros de las
empresas privadas verdad pues bien en
china 12 de las empresas más grandes son
propiedad del gobierno y esto incluye a
los principales bancos del país y
empresas de electrónica y
electrodomésticos como por ejemplo high
sense que fabrica televisiones y
teléfonos móviles
la economía china está tan hiper
regulada que solamente se pueden crear
esas empresas que aprueba el gobierno es
decir en cualquier país capitalista
tú puedes montar cualquier tipo de
empresa siempre y cuando esté dentro de
la ley en china el estado puede negar te
un permiso solamente porque no quiere
que hagas la competencia a una de sus
empresas estatales de hecho antes de
montar tu propio negocio primero
necesitas comprobar que tu proyecto
concuerda con el plan quinquenal del
gobierno chino que lo puedes consultar
por internet y si os interesa lo podéis
encontrar en los links de la descripción
puedes consultar su plan quinquenal para
entender lo que quieres es algo así como
la lista de deseos que el gobierno chino
quiere conseguir las tres cosas
principales que buscan son pasar de ser
una economía basada en las exportaciones
a ser una basada en el consumo e
incrementar su eficiencia medioambiental
y acabar con la contaminación
es más casi todas esas empresas
estadounidenses o europeas que vemos que
se establecen en china están obligadas a
asociarse con una empresa local o con el
propio gobierno es decir que se trata de
un sistema económico mixto que combina
es cierto algunos elementos del
capitalismo siempre y cuando encajen con
la estrategia a largo plazo del partido
comunista chino partido comunista que no
tiene ningún problema en utilizar las
herramientas que ofrecen los mercados
financieros
por ejemplo el propio gobierno chino
tiene su propio fondo de inversiones y
compran bonos de deuda de estados
extranjeros pero también acciones de
empresas por supuesto que no es el único
país que lo hace y ahí tenemos el
ejemplo del fondo soberano del gobierno
de noruega del que hablaremos
próximamente pero es curioso que un país
que se dice comunista aplique este tipo
de medidas verdad
como podríamos llamar a este sistema
político algunos lo llaman capitalismo
de estado otros dicen que es una
dictadura tecnocrática o un sistema
económico mixto lo cierto es que no es
ni comunista ni tampoco capitalista
y la pregunta es creéis que algún día
china llegará a tener un sistema de
libre mercado es más que veréis que
algún día china llegará a reconocer
derechos políticos y sociales a sus
ciudadanos podéis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios como
siempre si alguien quiere profundizar
más en este tema encontrareis varios
links en la descripción que os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y no
olvidéis en suscribiros al canal para
seguir todas nuestras actualizaciones
subimos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que no os lo perdáis podéis
suscribiros haciendo clic en este botón
un saludo y nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo hasta pronto
[Música]